the UFC is so new certain Fighters
there's training in MMA specifically in
their talented men when GSP was fighting
he's fighting very one-dimensional
Fighters there's a way to expose those
guys and it's not just peaceful but
Rogan's right where because the Sport's
so new like if you took Dak Prescott
who's good Prescott that's good that's
good if you toss them back in the 60s
he's the best to ever do it it's just
the type of change like you take Patrick
Mahomes and put them in the 50s he's
throwing 700 yards a game the game
evolves the science evolves the fighters
evolve they're better athletes GSP
wasn't fighting the same athletes that
the guys are today